بوتين يعلنها
حان وقت الحرب
وانتهى وقت التفاوض،
وأي شخص سيوقفنا أو سيحاول إيقافنا،
سيكون تحت مرمى أهدافنا،
وعلى جنود أوكرانيا ترك أسلحتهم
والعودة لمنازلهم
لأن الأمر سينتهي خلال ساعات...
، قصف روسي متواصل،
وخروج مناطق عديدة عن سيطرة
السلطات الأوكرانية،
اسقاط للدفاعات الأوكرانية،
وتدمير لمركز عمليات أوكرانيا
في دونباس بالكامل، بينما القوات
والدفاعات الأمريكية في أوكرانيا
لا تجرؤ على التدخل،
وجو بايدن يدعو رئيس أوكرانيا
للجوء إلى الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
الحرب باتت قائمة،
وصافرات الأنذار والأجراس  تقرع
، والرعب يدب القلوب
والناس يتهافتون لشراء المواد الغذائية
ويتجهون للأقبية،
وأوكرانيا اليوم تعيش في فوضى عارمة...
، لم يعد الأمر مجرد شرارة توتر
والمفاجآت تتوالى بمشاركة رسمية
لجيش بيلاروسيا في هذه الحرب،
، دقت ساعة الصفر،
الجيش الروسي ينقض على مدن أوكرانيا،
بعد انسحابات ذرت الرماد على العيون
ها هي روسيا تغزو الأراضي الأوكرانية،
، وأوكرانيا تعلن أن كل حدودها
تتعرض لهجومات روسية بيلاروسية،
لكن هل دخول القوات البرية الروسية
وسقوط ضحايا في غارات على كييف
ومدن أخرى يعني أقوى حرب
في العصر الحديث منذ حرب العراق؟
وإلى أين المصير أيها الدب الروسي؟
فلاديمير بوتين قرر إجراء عملية عسكرية خاصة
وخاطفة، وبدأ الغزو الروسي
لجميع المدن الأوكرانية
ووصل القصف حتى العاصمة كييف
التي يدق فيها جرس الإنذار
مرعبا السكان وسماع دوي الانفجارات
في العاصمة أيضا،،
وطالب بوتين الجنود الأوكرانيين
بإلقاء أسلحتهم على الفور والذهاب إلى ديارهم
فالحرب ستحسم خلال ساعات.
محذرا في الوقت ذاته أن أي تدخل أو تهديد
لأي طرف كان فإن روسيا سترد فورا
وسيؤدي ذلك إلى عواقب لم يروها في تاريخهم
فروسيا مستعدة لأي نتيجة،،،
بينما أعلن الانفصاليون سيطرتهم
على بلدتي ستانيتسا لوغانسكيا وشاستيا،
ويتحدثون بفرار القوات الأوكرانية
بأعداد كبيرة على طول خط التماس...
وتقارير عن سقوط مئات الجنود الأوكرانيين
جراء الهجمات الصاروخية لروسيا،
وأما في روسيا فهناك  تم تعليق العمل
في ١٢ مطارا جنوب وغرب البلاد
وإيقاف ١٩٠ رحلة جوية من مطارات موسكو.
( بداية الحرب)
بعد أن دخل الجيش الروسي إلى إقليم دونباس
لحفظ الأمن ها هو اليوم يعلن بداية الحرب،
وهذه مقاطع فيديو متداولة قيل أنها للعملية العسكرية
الروسية في الأراضي الأوكرانية،
وأظهرت أصوات انفجارات ضخمة
وقصف مدفعي.
وأعلن الرئيس الروسي، فلاديمير بوتين،
في كلمة متلفزة، شن عملية عسكرية
خاصة في أوكرانيا، محذرا من أن روسيا
سترد على الفور على أي تدخل أجنبي.
وأضاف بوتين أن تحركات روسيا تأتي
«للدفاع عن النفس من التهديدات
ومن مشكلات أكبر من الموجودة اليوم».
وخاطب بوتين الجيش الأوكراني قائلًا:
«آباؤكم وأجدادكم لم يقاتلوا،
لذلك قد تساعدون النازيين الجدد».
بينما ذكرت شبكة «فوكس نيوز» الأميركية
إن القوات الروسية بدأت دخول الأراضي الأوكرانية
من شبه جزيرة القرم.
وأما «رويترز» فأشارت إلى سماع دوي إطلاق
نار قرب مطار بوريسبيل في كييف،
بالإضافة إلى أصوات مماثلة لنيران المدفعية
في العاصمة الأوكرانية.
..
فيما الدفاعات والقوات الأمريكية المتواجدة
في أوكرانيا لم تمتلك الجرأة حتى
على الرد أو التدخل مع الحليفة كييف،
بينما الرئيس الأوكراني يعلن حالة الطوارئ
وحكومته تدعو المواطنين الأوكرانيين
إلى الاختباء في الملاجئ
مصطحبين معهم حاجياتهم الضرورية
للبقاء على قيد الحياة، ...
والمواطنون الأوكرانيون يعيشون حالة
من الفوضى لم يسبق لها مثيل في البلاد،
فهم يتهافتون على شراء المواد الغذائية
ويتزاحمون في الملاجئ والأقبية...
كل ذلك بالتزامن مع إعطاء رئيس بيلا روسيا أوامر لجيشه
بالمشاركة مع الجيش الروسي في الهجوم على أوكرانيا..
هنا بوتين يعلن تدمير البنية التحتية
لقوات الطيران الأوكرانية
و يضيف أن سلاح الجو الأوكراني
أصبح خارج الخدمة الآن..
وهنا يرد الرئيس الأوكراني بقوله.
نحن أقوياء ومستعدون لكل شيء وسننتصر..
وبينما تعلن كييف إسقاط طائرات روسية
ترد موسكو وتنفي ذلك نفيا قاطعا،،
مؤكدة عجز دفاعات أوكرانيا عن فعل ذلك...
(ردود الفعل العالمية)
الرئيس الأمريكي، جو بايدن،
يقول إن دعوات العالم مع الأوكرانيين،
وذلك تزامنا مع إعلان الرئيس الروسي
بدء عملياته العسكرية في أوكرانيا.
وقال بايدن:
«أراقب الوضع من البيت الأبيض وسأتحدث
إلى نظرائي في مجموعة السبع اليوم الخميس».
وأضاف بايدن في بيان:
«الرئيس (فلاديمير) بوتين اختار حربا
مع سبق الإصرار ستؤدي إلى خسائر فادحة
في الأرواح ومعاناة بشرية».
«و روسيا وحدها هي المسؤولة عن الموت والدمار
الذي سيحدثه هذا الهجوم. العالم سيحاسب روسيا».
ومجلس الأمن الدولي يعلن عن جلسة طارئة
حول بداية الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا..
أما بقية الردود فهنا
الرئيس الفرنسي: يطالب روسيا
بوقف عملياتها العسكرية ضد أوكرانيا فورا.
وهنا رئيس الوزراء البريطاني يقول:
الغرب لن يقف مكتوف الأيدي بينما يشن بوتين
حملته على الشعب الأوكراني.
خرج بوتين مرة أخرى ليقول :
نريد نزع سلاح أوكرانيا وتخليصها
من النازيين الجدد.
و في حالة حدوث تدخل أجنبي فإن روسيا
سترد على الفور.
في الجانب المقابل الرئيس الأوكراني يقول:
تواصلت مع قادة العالم لفرض كل العقوبات
الممكنة على روسيا والرئيس بوتين،
بوتين يرغب في تدمير بلادنا.
بعد أن كانت الحرب حبرا على ورق
بدأت روسيا أولى عملياتها في أوكرانيا
محققة أضرارا جسيمة فكيف ستكون النهاية
وما مصير العقوبات الغربية؟